hey what's up guys my name is ashana
welcome back to the game engine series
we are back with finally a new episode
for this new year hope you guys have had
an amazing break and i've had some time
to think about hazel i sure have
and to be honest i'm very excited for
this entire year because
i think this is the year that we finally
start actually making content with hazel
right so we're getting to a point where
we can
kind of hopefully after a few more like
important features that get implemented
in the first quarter of this year
hopefully
we'll be able to actually create games
with hazel and
build off of there which is going to be
great because the content is going to
start driving the development and
there's also a lot of
exciting stuff happening with hazel dev
so ultimately
lots of lots of cool stuff coming this
year everyone get excited
um uh but today we're gonna start off
with
uh this is gonna be like a bit of a mini
series of episodes really
so what's happening here is um basically
we're going to be implementing
something called mouse picking so that
basically lets us just click
click inside our viewport on an object
and pick it and select it right
which is obviously a very desirable
feature for an editor because we don't
want to be using the scene hierarchy
panel all the time
we want to just be able to just click on
the thing that we want to select um
and that's pretty uh that's that's
pretty standard stuff really
so there are a few ways of implementing
that um i did actually have
uh an episode uh well not only an
episode i did a live stream where i just
worked out how that would even work and
i tried out some suggestions
from what people were saying in the
community and stuff um and ultimately
played around with it and implemented a
solution to this whole mouse picking
problem
i've posted a live stream here on
youtube so check it out i'll have it
linked up
there um ultimately we're going to be
kind of
working in that direction because that
live stream was just me working out how
to actually do it in the first place
and there were of course a lot of like
hacks and a lot of like
you know me me not not developing a
proper api and not actually writing good
maintainable code because i just wanted
to see
i just want to get the idea down in as
short as time as possible that's usually
how i like to work
i like to i like to actually get the get
the code working
first and then sort it out and make it
you know more kind of uh
it's the right word uh i guess generic
maybe or extensible to it or just
essentially integrate it into the actual
engine code base a little bit better
last time though we actually in the game
engine series not the live streaming
stuff
we i'll have the video linked up there
we implemented the editor camera so now
if we
hit f5 to run this
um we'll be able to see that we can move
around
our world and i'll show you a little bit
about what i mean with the whole mouse
picking thing in case you're not
familiar with it so we have this
uh cube it's not really a cube it's
actually left right
and top is made up of three quads here
that are just essentially
um entities that we have in 3d space now
for one for all intents and purposes
this is in fact in 3d space
right this this is 2d 2d geometry it
just happens to be two-sided because we
haven't uh because we've disabled
culling but
um backface culling but uh this is this
is essentially
3d you could say 3d geometry in a 3d
world right
um and obviously the camera and
everything proves that so
in our 3d world how do we then click on
something to select it so if i want to
if
i want to select this kind of left face
over here
i want to be able to click on it and
then that will of course select it
inside the scene hierarchy display the
relevant properties
display the gizmo for me so that i can
actually move it around and do all the
stuff that i might want to do with it
how do we implement that so again lots
of different solutions but
what we're going to be doing is
basically a little technique here where
we
render we basically rasterize the entire
scene
so we run through a render pass we
rasterize the entire scene
to a frame buffer but instead of
actually rasterizing and essentially
writing the color value of it of every
pixel
we're going to write the entity id for
every pixel
so in other words if we were to look at
the
rasterized buffer we would just see a
bunch of entity ids where maybe we clear
it to negative one so if we click
outside and we
we select something it's going to be
negative one and it won't be an entity
but then um if we look at our entities
here they have essentially ascending
ideas here zero one two three
so if we click on for example this one
it's going to actually select this
left entity and then uh the way that
that will work is obviously
these pixels will just all be set to
zero and then these pixels over here
will all be set to
like one and then the camera is two so
all of these pixels will be set to three
uh and that'll that'll be the data
that's going to be stored inside this
additional texture um that we basically
render data to rasterize data to
okay it's a little bit difficult to
explain but you'll see it in practice
and it's very
simple and then all we have to do is
just simply
work out a way to um basically
convert our mouse position into some
kind of coordinate within that texture
and then all we have to do is sample a
pixel at that coordinate and see what
color it is it's not really going to be
a color it's just going to be an integer
that's going to be
0 1 or 3 in this case and then or
negative 1
and then when we click on it we'll pick
that color and then we'll just simply
set that to be our selected entity again
if you want to see this kind of you
can't wait for the series of episodes in
which we implement this
um the video that i have linked up there
the mouse picking one that will actually
show how i
implemented this and how i actually
worked through it and implemented it for
the first time because i had never done
this before
um i i did a different way of mouse
picking inside hazel dev and i haven't
never done this before
up until that live stream and that
that's kind of why live streaming is
great i think and there's a lot of um
there's a lot of good stuff here uh
and um uh twitter tv slash the channel
which i'll have
linked in the description below is uh
where i usually stream
and it's a really good place i think to
um to see kind of how i work and if you
want to interact more with the community
and
all of that then definitely check that
out okay cool anyway so that's kind of
how this works
um hopefully that makes sense
and again the video the the live stream
will clear more stuff up if you want
more
but the problem is that to facilitate
this um
we really need to think about how we get
this additional data
now we could have an additional render
pass where we basically run through
every object in our scene
and then render it into that secondary
buffer
um or into we'll say into a buffer which
we'll call our id
buffer now in order to actually make
that happen though
we need to render our geometry
but then output the value for the
rasterized pixel
to be the entity id so how do we get the
entity id
into our fragment shader for that well
we could use a uniform
right that would that sounds pretty
logical i think but
the problem with that is that this isn't
a piece of geometry this isn't actually
an object or this isn't three
objects right what this is technically
is one draw call this whole thing right
because this is actually using our 2d
renderer
so since it's using our 2d renderer
what's actually happening is we're
streaming in these vertices
into our vertex buffer dynamically and
then just
drawing them all in one batch so because
that's the case we can't set a uniform
per object in this case because again
even though this appears
to be three different objects it's
really just
one draw call um which is good because
we don't want to waste three draws on
this this is silly
right we can easily batch it together
but for the purposes of this color
buffer
or this id buffer we have a little bit
of a problem okay so what can we do well
uh obviously we can uh put it into the
vertex buffer itself
right so every vertex has an id um and
that id is essentially
which object that vertex belongs to
which entity that vertex belongs to and
that's what we're going to do
okay so great so what we're going to do
is again we're going to extend that
vertex buffer layout we're going to add
this but what about
that separate pass does that mean that
we have to recreate our entire batch but
with an additional vertex
attribute and how is that even going to
work so
this already sounds very messy and
that's what we just that's what i
i also thought that during the live
stream where i worked this out for the
first time anyway
um so what we're going to do instead is
we're not going to do an additional
render pass or anything like that but
it's going to add
another color buffer to our another
color attachment to our primary frame
buffer and just do it all in the one
render pass so
so at the moment we have a single render
pass it renders this entire
scene right what we're going to do is
instead of just outputting the color
which is the buffer we're looking at
right now this is our rasterized color
we're actually going to output two
things we're gonna we have two
render targets we have one which is the
color buffer which remains untouched but
then we're gonna add another one
that's gonna be the entity id and it's
just gonna be a buffer with a whole
bunch of entity ids right
because at the end at the end of the day
it's called a color attachment but
really we're just dealing with numbers
we're just dealing with data and these
are just buffers
and buffers of memory so we're just
going to create another buffer attach it
to our frame buffer because you can do
that you can have multiple writer
targets of course
um and then what that's going to do is
let us
um it's going to it is going to let us
not add another render pass it's going
to make it so that we can just do it all
in one render pass and not be wasteful
because we don't want to run through all
the objects in our scene a second time
and render them to something else if we
can just do it all in one pass it's a
lot more efficient
okay so that being said how do we then
do that how do we add an additional
attachment to our frame buffer and this
is really where this episode is going to
come in sorry for the very long
backstory
but um if we look at our current frame
buffer class so opengl frame buffer
that's our implementation you can see
that it's very uh
well it just kind of gives you this and
that's it
right so if we walk through this roughly
it creates a frame buffer
and then we attach a color attachment to
it we attach a color buffer
that's rgba 8 and rgba unsigned bytes
it's basically
like a an integer color here right
and then it's got a depth buffer that's
depth 24 stencil a
this is very uh
very not flexible right we don't want
every frame buffer we ever create in our
engine to be exactly this specification
that doesn't make any sense right i mean
for one
when we do like maybe hdr rendering we
want to maybe use floating point values
here so like six rgb a16f or 32f
right um we want this to be gel float
what about
if we uh want more than one attachment
what if we don't want any color
attachments because we're doing a depth
pass
for our shadow mapping and what if it's
a depth bars it doesn't need the stencil
buffer so what if i just want depth 32
right all of these kind of scenarios and
there are a lot
mean that we want some kind of flexible
way to define
exactly what our frame buff is going to
be like so what how many attachments
does it have what types of the
uh are the attachments do we have a
depth buffer that kind of stuff
so let's create a system uh for that now
hazeldev i've
written something very similar for hazel
dev right i've written something
uh basically i've come up with just a
nice api for us to be able to deal with
this stuff and it's kind of inspired by
the api that i came up with
for vertex buffers so you can see that
if i go into like render a 2d for
example
we have a little vertex buffer layout
situation where we're able to just
specify a whole bunch of uh
types right for all of our attributes
and then a name
now the name doesn't really do much and
we actually discussed this in the
earlier stream that i had today i had
another stream today
which i had to abandon halfway through
because i had to do some stuff but um
ultimately uh we talked about this a a
bit where these names are usually more
kind of they more apply to like
attribute semantics and stuff in hlsl
because uh this kind of system is
something that i wrote for sparky
um and sparky supports directx and
opengl spark is an
old engine that i wrote about six years
ago um
so it doesn't these names don't really
do anything for opengl
they do for directx um but anyway the
point is though we have a nice little
list
of attributes so why not do the same
for these attachments right why not be
able to specify a list of attachments
and i'll show you what the api looks
like so
this is hazeldev this is our scene
renderer which basically
creates a whole bunch of different like
render passes and stuff like that
and so it obviously has this little
frame buffer specification and
we also create a whole bunch of frame
buffers so the way that we create frame
buffers is we pass in a specification
right and then this specification has a
list of attachments
and you can see that in this case this
is our geometry pass so this is like our
main kind of path where we actually
render all of the objects in the scene
and of course this in general if you
haven't seen hazel dev i'll link a video
up there
but uh hazel dev is obviously a lot more
advanced than what we have inside hazel
at the moment we're doing like 3d
rendering
um and all of that and this scene has
like shadows and a whole bunch of
different render passes
and it's hdr and everything so the way
that it works is we
basically define this list of
attachments so you can see that in this
case for the geometry frame buffer
we have an rgb a16f buffer an rgba16f
buffer and a depth buffer
right so what we're actually doing here
is we're saying i want two color buffers
i want them to be
this type and i want a depth buffer
pretty simple right and then
there's some other options for like
multi-sampling um and the clear color
but that's kind of it or look at this um
compositing buffer right this is kind of
our main kind of scene composite buffer
so this is an rgb a8 because obviously
we're going to be displaying it
on a 8-bit display most likely um
so we're outputting just an rgb a8 kind
of
we're rendering the compositing pass to
an rgba
8 texture and we're doing the tone
mapping and all that stuff and you can
see there's no depth buffer because
we don't need one um another good
example is
the uh the shadow map pass right so the
shadow map pass
we create like a 4k texture here and you
can see it's just got that depth 32f
because we don't need any stencil
buffers we don't need any color buffers
it just needs to be a depth buffer and
that's all it is right
um and we've also got some other
parameters in this case like no resize
because we obviously don't want the
texture to scale
along with the um
the window resizing whereas these ones
we do because they're the main kind of
viewport buffers
so anyway that that's how it works
inside hazeldev and someone um
also said that what if we want uh
certain texture filtering
right so what if we want to have um
you know linear filtering or nearest
filtering or what about like wrap modes
like clamp and all that stuff
um repeat how do we set that up well the
thing is this list of attachments is not
just a bunch of texture formats
right what it actually is is frame uh
frame buffer attachment
specification the way i've implemented
it which is this
which has an initialized list of frame
and and stores a vector of frame buffer
texture specification
which is this right which um i added
this during the last live stream isn't
really implemented but anyway
which you can see is that texture format
and we have a constructor which lets us
implicitly construct it just by using
the texture format which is one of these
right but um we can also add wrap and
stuff to it which means that if we
wanted to
not have the default wrap of like clamp
or whatever or maybe we wanted
um some kind of filtering we can just
add it here where we can just do like uh
what is the texture wrap
um repeat or something like that if we
for some reason wanted it and if we had
a constructor for that that would work
right so we can
uh kind of add more detail if we want to
but if not we just
uh rely on that implicit constructor and
then we can
literally just specify a list of formats
and we get all of our frame buffers and
then obviously
all of our texture attachments for the
frame buffer so we go and then obviously
the frame buffer has to go through that
list and then
when it gets invalidated and actually go
through and create all these textures
so that's how hazeldev works i really
like this system
i've been using it for the past few
months and
yeah i think it's really clean and it
works really well all right cool
so let's pop in over to uh
our code and start implementing
something like this so again
the way that i like doing this let's
even i don't even know where we create
the frame buffer to be honest so let's
go ahead and um
research for that now let's go back to
edit a layer
and then i want to see uh do we do it
here i guess this scene do we have a
scene renderer we don't have a scene
renderer yet maybe the scene just does
it
um or not how on earth do we render
anything does
renderer do it
how does rendering work in hazel
i'm serious where on earth do we create
that frame buffer
frame buffer let's go ahead and find it
i have not pre-written the code for this
i will be referring to hazel dev
tesla def's code but uh this specific
code i haven't written
for this episode um okay so here we oh
okay it is inside of the layer so we
create a frame buffer here
and then i think we
yeah and that that's essentially that
that's the frame buffer that we
eventually display in the viewport as
well
um and then that's the one that we
resize here and that we bind before
rendering okay cool
okay so that's fine so when we create
this frame buffer
right which happens over here you can
see we we actually already have that
specification here
but this specification doesn't have it's
got frame buffer format and all that
stuff
i mean i don't remember talking about
this stuff but ultimately what it
doesn't have
is again that little list that we're
going to be discussing today which is
going to be a list of
texture formats so the first thing i
want to do is specify a
enum class and this is going to be our
frame buffer texture format now why am i
not using
um texture formats and that was a good
point i think that i thought about
certain textures don't have formats at
the moment which is not good
but i think i wanted to keep this
separate just because like the
the way that it works is um these aren't
necessarily standard textures
so we also have things like depth and
stencil
and those aren't really like textures
that you would ever create as part of
the texture api but there are there are
things that you would want as part of
the frame buffer api
so there is a bit of a difference okay
so i'm literally just going to copy some
of these formats and stuff from
um hazel dev but i'm not going to go
ahead and implement all of this stuff
right here right so in fact i'm not
going to add a number to these things so
color
and depth stencil depth
24 stencil 8 so this is the stuff that
we're using at the moment
and then i'll set a default as well so
the reason i'm doing this is just
because
we if we explicitly want to want it to
be this we'll do that but otherwise
we'll just specify depth and it should
sort it out for us
okay so i haven't really done anything
new here
right all i've done is i've added uh and
the idea here is that when we do add
like for example then when we do have
the need for like
um rgb a16f we'll just add it here so i
don't want to like overcome well
nice one um so i don't want to like over
complicate anything now because we
definitely don't need those formats just
yet
um i'll i will add them as required
okay so now the next thing is we create
a struct called frame buffer texture
specification
right and this is the thing that
actually contains the specification for
a texture so
these are just the formats right this is
the actual physical
specification of a texture so the format
the wrap and the uh filtering right
so um we'll have uh i'll make the
constructor
frame buffer texture specification we'll
just have a default constructor
and then we'll have a constructor that
takes in one of these texture formats
and this is going to be an easy one all
this is going to do is set the
texture format which we have yet to be
a format right
and then we'll have frame buffer texture
formats
format texture format
okay and then again i'll leave it to do
here because we probably won't get it to
get to this today
um this will just be the beginnings
because i spent quite a quite a long
time
um uh and there's like some gifting and
stuff going on i'll deal with you later
stream sorry
recording an episode i should get that
stuff to appear anyway
um so uh
yeah so we'll deal with this stuff a
little bit later maybe maybe in the next
episode because i do want to complete
this to an extent
um with that but i don't want to waste
too much time here and i want you guys
to get the
uh kind of main idea since this is more
of an introduction
okay so we've got this so this
represents each individual
texture that we add to our frame buffer
and then finally we need the collection
of them
we could kind of add it here but i don't
want to because we want to have some
extra stuff on top of this
and you'll see what i mean in a minute
so this is frame buffer attachment
specification
and specifically this is the collective
frame buffer attachment right so this is
these are all of them
um and the way that this kind of
manifests itself is that it has a list
a vector of these textures
and we call these attachments um and
then i'll go ahead and
create like a default constructor as
usual just to make sure that we have
that because
we're going to also add a constructor
that takes in an
initializer list of
these texture specifications so this is
what lets us kind of write it this is
very similar by the way to what i did
with the vertex buffer layout
so if you're confused or if you want to
see another example of this general like
what is an initializer list how does
this work
um if you go to vertex buffer um then we
also have
you can see a buffer layout with
initialized list of elements um maybe we
don't need to do a const reference i'm
not sure
um but then again that was a list of uh
enums there's a list of classes which i
mean
you know okay whatever we'll we won't
add a const reference
never know these days when you want your
constant reference and when you don't
but anyway um and we'll have a bunch of
attachments here uh
which we'll just set like this so we'll
construct the vector with the
attachments
with the initialized list um that's
it right and then obviously the last
thing we have to do
is have the actual attachments here so i
called these
attachments as well these are just our
attachments
so now the cool thing is this whole
thing changes right
now what we do is we say fpspec dot
attachments equals
and we specify our attachments so frame
buffer texture format rgba8
and then frame buffer texture format
um uh depth just depth right we don't
care we just want to default the
depth buffer right now we're creating
this
um so this obviously looks better
because for for one
by creating a frame buffer we're aware
of what on earth it is before it was
like implicitly implied
and pleasantly implied that's funny that
it would be this which is just
ridiculous we want to actually see that
here
i mean it's fine to have a default
potentially but
um i i like to be quite verbose with my
programming i guess i like to actually
clearly specify what is happening
because otherwise it's just a mess i
think um but anyway so we have that
and um now we need to actually make it
do something so if we go back to opengl
frame buffer this is all great but
obviously
we haven't changed any of the code it's
still uh it still kind of
remains as is so our next step is going
to be to change this around so that we
can actually create
all the attachments necessary so when
invalidate happens which might be on
resize obviously resize calls and
validate as you can see
um we create the frame buffers that's
fine this is the attachment specific
stuff
so attachments um so from here all the
way to here
we create a color buffer and a death
buffer and attach them
so let's go ahead and change this so
first of all
if um our and this this this is actually
something that we
need to do i think i did i did them
somewhere here
um we basically need to
uh where did i do this okay
so one one thing one thing that we have
that's a bit of an advantage so
one of the things we need to do is
basically easily sort our attachments
into into two categories
depth and color right
because at the moment we have a list of
attachments but some of them are color
some of them are depth
and for some reason i decided to handle
them separately
right so the way that i did this was uh
and the thing that's interesting here is
that
inside invalidate um invalidate is
basically i haven't talked
much about this i think but invalidate
is an interesting function because
invalidate means that something has
changed inside
our frame buffer and it needs to be
it's no longer valid right so a good
example is the width and height
now whether or not specification with an
id change
a bit of a different question um because
maybe we want to maintain the original
width and height no matter what
no matter if it gets resized so we might
deal with that later
but um there's two ways you could go
about this you could assume that
the specification that a frame buffer
gets created with
is set in stone meaning that if you want
a different
spec suddenly create a new frame buffer
this frame buffer is going down with a
ship
it has this spec right not in terms of
width and height because that's
somewhat arbitrary right depends what
it's for but it's somewhat arbitrary
we'll say
but in terms of the rest of the
specifications such as like
hey is this multi-sampled is this
um a swap train target is it
what attachment does it have you could
say that's set in stone
um and again you don't have to but if
you do it means that inside the
constructor itself you can for example
sort out the attachments into those into
those categories
right and i think that's what i'm going
to do so i could do it in
invalidate but the thing is i don't
necessarily think it's work that we need
to do
every time we resize the frame buffer
because
we already should know what the
attachments are they're not going to
change just because our frame buffer
gets resized
that's why some people have like you
could have a resize function instead of
invalidate or resize and invalidate but
invalidate to me just means recreate the
whole thing
um so that's what we'll do here so what
i've done in hazeldev and what i'll do
here is i'm basically going to go
through
all of the attachments right which is
what this is
and i'm going to check to see if it's a
depth format and if it is i'm going to
put it into my color attachments
otherwise into my depth attachment so
the way that i did this was
i basically had two little piles inside
here i had um
a vector and we'll assume that we have
one depth buffer i don't even know if
you can have two i'm
not sure i've ever done that before
usually you have one depth buffer
um so uh we'll do frame buffer texture
format and these are going to be our
color attachment formats
so you can see we've got a vector of
them and then i'm just going to have
a depth uh buffer format
depth buffer uh depth attachment i'll
call it format
and this is also why i had that frame
buffer none thing because i want to have
a default i want to have a
like an invalid state right so i want to
have like what's not that it's invalid
it's just that
it's it's empty i want to have an empty
state i want to have a depth buffer
format
that isn't really real and that way
obviously i can check to see if that's
none or not
um and if it's none then it doesn't
exist and i have no depth buffer
so what i'll do here um and i i wrote a
little function inside hazel dev called
is depth format um which i just wrote
inside here
so let's just write it here for now
static bull is depth format
frame buffer texture format um and then
in hazel dev this does something very
simple
and for us it'll be even simpler all it
has to do is basically check to see is
it
this this is the only depth format we
have at the moment just one
and so we can just switch on format um
the reason i'm doing a switch on an f is
because we'll add more
formats later like depth 32f um
and so i don't want to uh
i'm just kind of allowing for that i
guess um
okay so uh case
framework texture format
okay um all right
so there we go so we we return true if
it's that um
and then otherwise we return false
pretty simple stuff
i mean in fact i'm going to put this
into a namespace called utils
because it's uh we might move it out of
this class we'll see
and so all i'm going to do is over here
i'm going to check to see
uh if so i'll do the opposite case first
so if utils
is depth format um and then format
so if it's not a depth format i'll add
it to color attachment just because it's
probably
we're probably only going to have one
death buffer and it just makes more
sense this way
um so we'll do uh i guess we're gonna do
in place back i don't think it'll matter
too much in this case
um else
and this format should be uh i think we
should do
format texture format um else we'll set
our depth attac
again we should only have one
technically possible to put in both i
don't know if we want to protect against
that
but otherwise we'll set that attachment
format so what this is doing is upon
construction it's just sorting out that
list right and
seeing hey you know what you know
what's your situation with the color and
depth um and unfortunately i've got
errors and stuff which is a
little annoying um all right let's sort
this out quickly and that was annoying
um so it's not happy with this uh format
dot texture format is what we actually
want to in place
right so what what we should see at this
point in time is color attachment we
have one rgb a8 and depth attachment we
have one depth
24 cents late so it's just sorted it
into basically one of two buckets
um okay cool so inside invalidate now
what do we do well we have to go
through all of our um attachments and
set them up so
for uh order and what is this exactly
this is a
framework protection format so this is
just formats right so for order
um auto format inside
uh and the thing is i did it i did it
this way but
i probably shouldn't have done it
exactly this way because what about
different filtering modes why did i do
it this way inside hazeldev
probably just for fun because i like to
break things
um let's instead actually take in
this i think so framework protection
specification
right depth buffer probably not too
important
although it might be let's do this
instead
so these are our color attachment
specs and depth attachment spec
and i'm doing this because um i guess we
can have a default one because
by default we haven't set this up
actually we should have
by default our texture format we should
set to none
right this will just make sure that if
we hit the default constructor um
it will set the texture format to none
and then we can check for that to see if
for example the depth buffer doesn't
exist right so this just
we just do that to this right depth
attachment
[Music]
specs
i like to write it out um
so color attachment specification just
for my specification uh
depth attachment specification okay
uh yep and we checked the format
okay spec that's better that's an
improvement i'll probably
try and merge that into hazel dev okay
so we go through all of these specs
right so
for uh auto spec uh you can i don't know
about copying it but we don't need to um
color attachment specifications and then
basically what we want to do here
is for one see exactly what format it is
and then based on the format we probably
want to create it right
so the way that i do it in hazel dev is
i have another utility function called
create textures
um and i think this basically just
creates a texture with the given
target so this is based on whether or
not it's we're not really dealing with
multi-sampling at the moment
but um what i do here
uh is a number of things actually and i
think that
we might want to have yeah okay
this this gets a little bit complicated
in order to us in a scalable way so
let's do it this way
so first of all we'll check to see if we
have a color attachment
um and if we have a color attachment
right meaning that like we
we actually just have uh any color
attachments whatsoever
i'm going to uh first of all get the
actual color attachments which we don't
have at the moment
and they're going to be renderer ids
right so we'll create a vector of
so we have a vector for specifications
but now we're going to have a vector of
renderer ids
right and there's red already no thing
neon 32t
then it is uh and this is going to be
our
color attachments
and then we're gonna have one of these
for our depth attachment
okay buckle in because this uh
episode is about to take off
it's gonna be a lot of work in a minute
so um if that's the case and we'll have
to rewrite this anyway but whatever
if this is the case then the first thing
i want to do is take
our color attachments and resize them
to the right size right this is just to
avoid unnecessary allocation inside our
backyard
so now that we've re now that we've
resized them let's go ahead and write
another utility function called create
textures
right um and again this will deal with
multi-sampling and stuff but not
not at the moment so um we'll tell it to
create maybe
with a specification
well i think it just needs to be either
true or false so
um we'll add a little bull multi-sample
equals uh specification dot samples
greater than one
and then we'll have a little boolean for
whether or not this is a multi-sample
texture
um and then we will uh so we're creating
the textures and i guess
we just need the actual data and size
because that's what opengl wants so
we'll do
color attachments dot data
i could just pass them in but anyway um
color attachments dot
size you'll see what this ends up being
in a minute
um so what this is going to be is
basically
uh static void create
textures bull multi
sampled um and then we're going to have
our uint
32t which is really just a glue and
probably should use urban gels type but
do add id and then count so that's going
to be where it stores the uh
outputs um and then we do gel create
textures
uh we'll write another function called
texture target
with multi-sampled uh and then we do uh
uh what so at the moment i just did that
did i
that's a bit weird that looks like a bug
hmm anyway it should be count and
out id but for some reason i
just have one here inside hazel dev
weird okay whatever um so static void
uh sorry static gl enum texture target
very easy simple function just returns
uh
gl texture tv multi-sample
or gl texture 2d so i guess i am
implementing multi-sampling in a way
here
oh well um okay so
that looks good to me for now um while
we're here we might as well add some of
the other
utilities that we'll need such as bind
texture the reason i'm doing this is
because
um we i didn't want to talk about
multi-sampling today but sometimes it's
hard to
copy like half of hazel dev's code um
but ultimately
uh the reason we're doing this is
because the
texture target right um
so what we bind here um
and yeah we if we use direct direct
state access we don't need any of this
anyway we'll write it like this for now
because that's consistent with the rest
of our api
but the texture target is going to be
the gel texture 2d or gl texture 2d
multi-sample depending on whether or not
it's multi-sampled and so because we
don't know that
um you know instead of doing branches
and switching everywhere we just have
some convenience functions that do that
for us
okay um i'll call yeah that's fine okay
so we have these for now
and again that just means that when we
actually go through this
if we have any color attachments we'll
create we'll
fill this color attachments vector with
because we've resized it
we'll actually just write into the data
and we'll write all will generate a
whole bunch of opengl ids for each color
attachment all in one go which is good
okay so that's what's happening in there
hopefully that makes sense
now the next step is going to be to
actually create the texture so we've
created the uh well we've created the
textures but we haven't specified what
format they're going to be or anything
like that
we haven't allocated the memory for them
which is what we need to do
so we have to go through um i'll leave
that in i equals zero
and we'll do size t
i equals zero oh my goodness me
i is less than specifications size i
plus plus
um and we can probably just use color
attachment size it doesn't really matter
this should be the same
um utils bind texture and again
multi-sample uh so that we support that
and then we're going to bind
color attachments i so color attachments
remember they're our render ids
right so we're binding color attachments
i'm um
i don't really want to call it color
attachment renderer ids so i'm leaving
it
as that but obviously if you look at it
and you see that it's uwens you should
be able to tell
uh okay so um
next step is to uh basically create what
we need based on the format
so we'll do switch on color attachment
uh
specifications i which remember these
match up
so color attachments i and color
attachment specifications i
match up because we've created well
they're going to be the same size and we
are obviously going through them from
zero to
um to the end so we basically check to
see
the texture format of the current color
attachment specification
and if it is a frame buffer texture
format rgba8
um it's basically going to be either it
has to be that actually at this point in
time
that's the only color specification we
actually have
so at this point we'll uh call another
utility function called attach color
texture
we'll give it the renderer id
we'll give it the amount of samples
um we'll give it gl rgba8 and of course
this is coming from hazeldev by the way
patreon.com to the channel if you want
to get access to the complete source
code of my 3d version of hazel
um specification width specification
height and i which is the index
all right now let's go ahead and
implement this function not gonna be
that bad i promise
um so static void attached this is the
really the the big one right and again
we need to expand this and include more
um uh formats in the future
but that's really all we'll be will be
expanding everything else should just be
scalable so height and
index
so again bull multi-sample to quickly uh
create one of these uh because we
actually need the amount of samples as
well as whether or not it's
multi-sampled
so if it's multi-sampled um then we'll
do gl text image 2d multi-sample
gl texture 2d multi-sample samples
format with isgl false
okay read the documentation if you don't
understand this but it's very similar to
normal text image except we just
supply the number of samples right
internal format is going to be rgba8 as
we passed in here
uh over here right with height is
self-explanatory and
this is just fixed sample locations we
just set that to false
in most cases really um but again
consult the documentation okay so
um gl text image 2d
otherwise so if it's not multi-sampled
which is currently we we're not
currently we don't really deal with
multi-sample textures um it'll be the
same except we're on a different
function
so not text image 2d multi-sample just
text image 2d
and we're passing a different target and
then from here
level 0 internal format is going to be
format um
width height is going to be yup with
height
um border is zero now format is the
access format which we'll keep as
glr gba this is uh so we have two
formats internal format which is how
opengl
stores the data and then format which is
how we access the data
so what like the incoming data so
sorry yeah format is the incoming data
right incoming data and
the storage type so uh yeah
we'll just leave this um as glrgba
and gl unsigned byte for now
right we'll have to have a conversion
function because this might be like
float
or int um in the future
but for now we'll leave that as is and
then we'll just do another pointer right
um now at this point we need to set all
the filtering stuff
right so um
[Music]
the filtering and the wrap which we
should have just
taken in the specif the spec right
because that has the format
anyway but this is an opengl format now
right
so yeah okay so again the filtering and
stuff we said we do later
um uh
filtering um well yeah i don't even need
to write this
because what we'll do is we'll go
through gel text parameter um i
uh we'll do texture target because again
this this um
uh we'll notice this won't be
multi-sample because
oh this is a bug inside hazel as well
wait what how does that work
ah apparently you don't need to set
that's weird isn't it
um i might have to take a look at this
later um but basically we'll do texture
target multi-sampled in this case it'll
always be false though so there's a
really
probably no point running that um i'm
not sure why i'm not setting parameter i
for i'm not setting these like
parameters for um
for multi-sample textures maybe maybe
because different ones apply or
something
well like yeah i guess minification
magnification for multi-sampling is
different okay whatever um
and then we'll do wrap gl
texture wrap so this
you know we'll do rst clamp to edge
so um basically
you like at the moment we're just
setting this to linear and clamp to edge
but
you know depending on a lot of things
including well this is a frame offer so
i'm not sure about mit maps and stuff
but
yeah that could be useful um anyway this
stuff will be set from the frame of
frame buffer specification in the future
um that's kind of it again
i said it wouldn't be too difficult um
the next thing we need to do though
so if we had two of these it would work
right it would just add it to
uh to two different things now why do we
have
the index though because the index so
far has been useless
was that just something that i never
implemented oh whoops i didn't attach it
good thing i went back so gl frame
buffer texture 2d
geoframe buffer right this is the
attachment code i think we've already
got one of these here
right so let's copy it let's pop it in
except this time we're going to do color
attachment zero plus
index right and the id is obviously
going to be id
and that's it and this is
going to be going to go through texture
target
all right so that's it we've created our
textures
we've allocated memory for them right
and then we've
attached them to our frame buffer at the
correct index
um and that's what this does and so
obviously if we run this twice we'll
we'll we would have created two textures
that are going to be attached at color
attachment 0 and color attachment 1
which is great all right so next stop
is the depth attachment right
so again it's possible to not have them
so we need to check it first
so but it's not a vector so we could do
if depth attachment specification
doesn't equal
sorry texture format doesn't equal
none then it's valid right so we have to
basically create a texture
except this time we'll create one
and it will go into oh oops one goes
here
and it will go into the depth
attachment slot um
and then we'll do uh yeah and we'll
leave multi-sample there
then we'll mine we'll bind it again
whether or not it's multi-sampled and
obviously depth attachment is what we're
binding
and then we need to basically do a
switch on the format so very similar to
this except there's no for loop because
there's just one
this is one of these so we do depth
attachment specification dot texture
format
again in this case we only have depth
depth 24 stencil
eight it's possible to have other ones
like depth 32f
uh is another popular one so
um we'll we'll set up our code for that
so attach
depth texture this is going to be a
different one um and we'll pass
in the depth attachment we'll pass in
the the number of samples
right which uh i thought we had but
we didn't that's inside here
and then for this in this case depth 24
stencil eight
uh and then what else did i have uh
gl depth stencil attachment because
it's possible again to just have a depth
attachment so we have to specify which
one
and this one does contain a stencil
buffer um and then
m specification dot width and
specification.height
that's it okay
so what is this all about um
so this is again going to be very simple
very similar to
um what we have before which is this
so we'll copy and paste this attach
depth texture
um so id samples
format um we'll add something else
though called
attachment type with height and then
we don't need an index sorry
multi-sampling still applies to depth
buffers that's fine
um and then over here
the difference is um well we'll do gl
text storage today
a few few differences and again i don't
really want to get into this too
much um it should work in all cases
though i think
um and then uh what do we have levels so
one level
internal format is going to be um
format and then we just have width and
height
uh we can leave our parameters uh and
then
finally uh framework for texture this
remains the same except the attachment
is now the attachment type so either
depth
um attachment or depth stencil
attachment
and then we have the multi-sampled and
then the id
and then the zero for the level in this
case
okay that's it um i think that is
actually the end finally so yeah lots of
code here suggest you guys i'll commit
this obviously after the episode
i suggest you read it um and maybe go if
you really don't understand how it works
i mean it's pretty simple it's just a
lot of actual code right
um but we basically just organize it in
a way that is completely responsive to
like a
dynamic kind of um collection of
specifications that it can use to
actually create this
this these physical uh open shell
objects basically okay
so that's how that works um
now finally though what we need to do is
we basically need to
check to see if the color attachment
size
is greater than one because if it is
then there's something
else that we have to do so first of all
we'll assume that for now we only
support a maximum of four color
attachments because the next block of
code is only going to support
four so we'll make sure that we have no
more than four color attachments
and then what i'm going to do is define
our draw
buffers this is something you need to do
on opengl if you actually want to draw
to
more than one uh render target so
basically what these are
are these kind of color attachments that
we define inside a
list inside a little array like this and
then we just do gl
draw buffers and we're basically
enabling them so for the amount that we
have and we've got an array that defines
four but we don't have to use all four
and that's what this is doing so we
basically say how many whoops how many
do we have here
um well what am i trying to do
constructive space
how many do we have here we have uh four
and then
what are the actual buffers so the
buffers are buffers
okay and that's it so that just enables
them for rendering
otherwise um if it's only a depth pass
and i don't know if this is strictly
necessary but basically else if m
color attachments size uh is zero
right so i guess we can do color
attachments empty
then um gl draw buffer
gl none only death pass might be like an
optimization thing maybe
okay um and again this would be used for
like uh
just a depth pass for things like shadow
mapping okay
um that is it i think
so we don't need any of this right we've
got that inside our other functions
um we should still check to see if it's
complete or not obviously it's very
important stuff
um but that is it and then we can unbind
it to make sure we don't actually we
don't accidentally render to it
um without me youtube wow
so when we invalidate it another thing
we should do by the way is make sure we
clear everything
because if the specification changes i
mean the thing is it probably won't
well yeah because what we're doing here
obviously is we're going through
everything again and we're
we're resizing stuff so i think that you
probably would want to
clear this because just the actual color
attachments not the specification
necessarily um
just the renderer ids because you've
just deleted them they're now pointing
to invalid ids so let's get rid of that
and then let's
set that depth attachment to zero as
well
okay um and that's that really is it i
think uh when we bind it and when we do
this stuff looks great to me as well
oh um yeah this is something that needs
to be addressed so
color attachment death attachment oh we
have another function called death
attachments great
great i'll delete this um so we don't
have a color attachment anymore
let's go ahead uh let's go through
deleting all this stuff so delete
textures now just takes in
um all of them at once so color
attachment oh someone just uh
subscribed oh it does show up in the
recordings i don't know what that does
okay good
cool cooler thank you for your
subscription also previously
lfix as well and uh sebia
gifting subs as well thank you to gives
yourselves to royal
anyway so much stuff so much stuff to
catch up on but
um it's been a long episode what are we
at right now 53 minutes incredible
telling you guys game engines are a
serious business
um i don't know what i'm gonna do with
these episodes um okay so we'll go
through all of them
and then color attachment
specifications.data right so this just
released them all in one go basically
and then the
depth attachment we can clear as
necessary um i don't i don't really know
what happens if you give it zero
will just not delete it i guess not
because i don't think hazel dev crashes
because of this
so um and sorry this is uh color
attachments not the specifications
um so let's do that here so we just
delete all of them and i guess if it's
zero it's not going to do anything
and i guess if that's zero maybe it
weren't deleted
i don't know if if anything we can wrap
it in an if statement obviously
and just only delete it if it's actually
valid if it's a if it's a thing
oh i think that's it let's just run it
maybe everything will work it should
look exactly the same it's already
failing to compile
color attachment undeclared identifier
uh get color attachment under id okay
well
this is a bit controversial because
which one are you talking about
um
index zero
uh return color attachments
index and corset
to make sure that index is uh less than
special color attachment size
um okay uh we've changed the signature
of this
let's go back
f5 search should work the same
we had a default parameter of zero
um okay so far so good so we didn't get
this the assertion or anything and we
see our ping cube is normal right
so what we should be able to do now
right is uh essentially add in
potentially another one of these
right um and now our frame buffer should
actually have two attachments i'm not
sure if this will work i mean i guess it
should
um
right and then we should be able to
actually draw to that if we
so so wanted to right um
in fact uh should we test this out i
guess we should test this out
so i think what i can basically do right
we've already
gone this far right so if i go to the
shader let's go ahead and just do layout
location one
red and color two we'll say
and then we'll just say color two equals
just red
right just red maybe let's do a nicer
red i don't want to
just completely ruin everyone's eyes
with a
full red just something like this right
nice little red
and then what we'll do so this this
should ideally everything should work
should we should still see the pink cube
right but then what i'm going to do
is when i actually uh bind well when i
actually
draw the viewport what i'm going to try
and do
is you can see i get the texture idea
give it to i'm going what if we get
index
1 so that's the second color buffer
so this should be red if everything has
worked correctly
and i believe it should have
there you go okay so you can see that
what we've got now is a shader that's
rendering to two targets
and we're able to easily create that
using a pretty nice specification api
i think that's my personal opinion
and then obviously we're able to render
to it perfectly well and read back from
it perfectly well as well
okay so that is the end of this
extremely long episode hope you guys
enjoyed it
um if you did if you're watching on
youtube don't forget to hit the like
button
and subscribe you can also help support
the series by going to patreon.com which
i'll
have a link in the description below too
as well where you can get access to all
of the hazel dev source code that led up
to
what you see here um you know we've had
this api for a while and obviously we're
actually using it to do stuff like
shadow mapping and
um you know various other passes and
compositing and whatever
so um uh yeah
and then obviously you'll be helping to
support the uh general
game engine series and my youtube
channel and everything here would not be
possible without all of you guys so
really i'm
thankful to everyone who subscribes on
twitch and to everyone who
um also supports on youtube thank you
guys for watching uh
don't forget to um don't forget to
follow the stream
if you want to catch more of these live
streams because this is streamed live
and i will see you next time goodbye
[Music]
you